so I my name is still serene I lead
engineering a game changer and I'm going
to talk about continuous delivery for
iOS now there's an asterisk next to that
because I think well most people here
probably know is you can't actually do
continuous delivery for iOS so I'm going
to explain actually what I mean and
explain what that what that asterisk is
so I'm going to tell you a little about
what we do at game-changer it'll help
it'll help explain a little bit of you
know what what I'm talking about um
we're a sports technology company where
we're in lower Manhattan on and we work
on amateur sports and basically the way
you can think of our product is amateur
sports like baseball softball basketball
those are the three sports that we work
on they they they do Rick they have
somebody on the team or a coach or
somebody who's doing record-keeping in a
paper score book and it basically
records everything that happens in the
game and then you don't go home after
that calculate statistics partly for
record-keeping partly to help of player
development partly for publicity and
that takes a couple hours and well along
we came and said well you know take this
free app record essentially everything
that happens in a basketball game or in
a baseball game and you can get free
stats instantly and so our our customers
love this they ask us about five times
how much it costs and we tell them it's
free and they eventually believe us and
they start using it and it's great in
the way that we work as of business is
that from here essentially a bunch of
data is getting uploaded to us and we
can generate a lot of great content from
that so people pay us eight dollars a
month so they can get like a live stream
of like you know essentially a
play-by-play of their kids game if they
stood or text message alerts when their
kid does something interesting or a
computer-generated recap story which is
surprisingly awesome so it's a fun thing
to work on and i'm going to talk
particularly about our app and our
release process now normally at huh um i
have come with my own laugh track which
is which is good so so I know there's
some folks here who might actually not
be familiar with the term continuous
delivery even though we are at the
continuous delivery meet up so what I'm
talking about is commit code it goes to
production within minutes that's the
idea of continuous delivery um that's a
that's a great thing you can't do that
with iOS but there's some great things
that continuous delivery does that we
want to do for iOS in particular lowers
risk it lowers waste and it decreases
time to market and so those are things
we all like and so we want to kind of
take what happens in continuous delivery
and make it happen in iOS now Fred
Wilson like you know a few years ago
continuous delivery continuous
deployment sometimes called got a lot of
got a lot of press and Fred Wilson
blogged about it said big changes create
big problems little changes create
little problems I realized that this
model I mean continuous deployment
continuous delivery doesn't work in
desktop software and mobile apps well I
sort of disagree even though I've
conceded that you can't totally do this
but what I'm going to argue today is
that the principles behind continuous
delivery on the web or things that you
can ply successfully to apps um so
really what I'm going to talk about
today is a little bit of theory about
kind of why this stuff works I'm going
to go through a case study eight game
changer and talk about how we how we
solved you know just case study of a
problem that we had a game changer talk
about how we solved it let me talk about
how this generalizes for four different
environments because not certainly the
things that we did are not going to be
exactly the things that other people are
going to want to do
so as I said like what we want out of
this is we want faster delivery we want
less waste meaning like wasting less
time wasting less money we want less
risk I mean both technical risk like you
know your app dies and your customers
are unhappy and product risk and
building something that people don't
want honor that doesn't kind of work
right or feel right and these things
like whether you do them on the app or
on the web are great so it's really
important to get beyond kind of this to
how this works and continuous delivery
works I i I'm picking out two reasons
that I think are important or that and
that are applicable to to mobile apps
one is small batches and I'll talk about
what I mean there and one is fast
feedback so you can't do continuous
production employee you can't do
automatic monitoring you can't do like
fast cycle a/b tests but these things
small batches and fast feedback or
things that you can do and it turns out
that they work so what do I mean by
small batches so in Eric Ries blogs
about this actually is quoting from the
Lean Thinking book so this is like a
third hand anecdote but but it makes
sense this is a picture of envelopes
that are stuffed so imagine people
stuffing newsletters like I don't know
if people did this I I had to do this
for my mom when I was a kid I don't know
if people still do this but ideas you
got a newsletter you need to fold it put
in an envelope address it and mail it
you need to do this like a hundred times
um so there's the in the story there's a
father and there and he's doing this
with his daughters and what the father
is doing is he's taking these
newsletters folding them stuffing them
in an envelope addressing them stamping
the envelope and he's doing that one at
a time so is essentially just packaging
one envelope putting it down getting the
next one getting everything ready
putting it down and his daughters like
no no no dad you're wrong what you need
to do is you need to fold like 25 you
know newsletters and then address 25
envelopes and then stuff 25 envelopes
and then stamp them and draw
and Mail on in these batches and it
turns out that like the dad wins the
race and that's completely surprising
and unintuitive to me and I think to a
lot of people and the reason is I mean
are there a couple reasons one is that
you you can undervalue a the amount of
time it takes to actually manage these
big batches like dealing with these big
piles and and moving them around and
making sure they don't fall over and
that kind of thing like there's some
effort in that that's easy to overlook
the other the other thing that's
efficient and it's good about these
about these small batches that's bad
about large batches is like well what if
you make a mistake like and I I'm
positive I did this at my wedding
because I did it the wrong way when I
was addressing invitations at my wedding
but like you know what if you write like
the address is upside down on like 20
envelopes well if you're doing it one at
a time you kind of realize that all your
piles the wrong way and you fix it and
you've got only one wasted one but if
you're doing like 25 at a time then well
you've wasted a lot of time so if you're
in an environment where errors happen a
lot like our environments on then small
batches or protect are especially nice
so this is this is really
counterintuitive but I think everyone's
observed that the software are you know
generally in technology we're moving
towards small batches when it comes to
release cycles so you know you you know
the one year release cycle some people
still do it I mean actually Apple does
it with iOS but a lot of people are
doing release cycles that are like a few
minutes or a few hours long and when we
talk about continuous delivery we're
often talking about doing a few hours of
work committing it and having it in
production or RT minutes of production
and and it changes the way that people
have to work so if you're developing
code that's going to go into production
in a couple minutes well and your twine
consciously to keep your batch sizes
down it means that engineers need to
think about keeping their check-in small
which is kind of a hard thing to do like
sometimes it's nice to just put your
headphones on and like stay there for
like a day or two go home and eat and
what not
like you know just just to concentrate
but like like changing that too well I'm
going to do really small commences it's
a mental shift um that's where feature
Flags get used you know so you can do
these small commits and hide things
behind feature flags until they're ready
means that when you do code review you
got to be really fast and responsive
because you're in this like small commit
mode so no like you know get a
conference room and get everyone
together and project code reviews on a
screen which is kind of how they used to
do at the beginning of my career which
makes me feel old your deploy process
needs to be really good I need to feel
the handle doing deploys like you know
dozens of time of day and it people
struggle people struggle with this but
um you do have less risk when you when
you do something like this because these
small batches is kind of like what fred
wilson was saying small changes create
small problems well if you've got a
really small batch the chance of
something and it's going to go wrong is
reasonably small because there's not a
whole lot of stuff there to begin with
it's uh and also means of course that
fewer things like if you do break
something you're building fewer things
that are broken on top of your whatever
bad assumptions or bad processes or bad
machinery that caused your batch to
spoil but when I say that I'm kind of
making an assumption and the assumption
that i'm making is that you have fast
feedback and what i mean is that if you
have a small batch it only kind of
really works if you know that your small
batch works or it doesn't work and
that's I think why continuous deployment
has worked really really well on the web
because fast feedback is really really
easy you've got automatic monitoring got
page or Judy you got you know your
graphs and your charts that update
pretty instantly so you can do these
like small batches know right away
whether you're broken something most of
the time and be pretty good um so I'm
going to talk about well I'm going to
talk about now this small batch and fast
feedback problem on at game changer and
I'm going to going to use an example
that we faced
so this is what this graph shows don't
worry too much if you can't read the
numbers this is essentially the average
time between submitting an app to Apple
for review and the time that Apple
authorizes you to release the app and
what this is basically saying like here
is like for like a little under four
days and here is like eight days
basically what it's saying is like four
to seven for 28 days it's about how long
it takes that's not a small batch right
you're you're the minimum batch of stuff
that's going through Apple's process is
going to be for 28 days and nobody even
does it that small because you probably
would annoy your customers if you're
giving them updates once a week and then
that means obviously your feedback isn't
fast either because you're going to wait
for 28 days to know whether what you're
doing is actually working in the wild so
we had an idea a couple years ago and we
started trying this out and I think
Chris Ricker who's here actually didn't
know I was going to put him on the spot
and he actually came up with this idea
which is like why don't we just do this
all but before we submit to apple so
what if we do this like kind of small
batch fast feedback process right before
it goes to apple and then we have to go
through their standard process so what
that would mean is this is kind of our
are like our build process our
deployment process for the app in a
nutshell before we've submitted for
review well on the top left is Jerry
he's he's one of our developers he
really likes baseball it really likes
iOS it's no secret no no no surprise it
works a game changer and you know he
commits like an hour's worth of code
that goes to Jenkins that's a that's the
fell in the middle of build automation
server Jenkins creates a build runs a
bunch of tests and then you know when
that all passes Jenkins goes uploads it
to hockey app so one of my colleagues
looked at this slide and he says hockey
absolutely looks like a toilet yeah
they're there they're German I don't
know um maybe it maybe makes sense there
I'm not sure so and then what hockey app
does is it's like a beta distribution
platform so the idea is you send
something a hockey app it basically all
of these here internal company devices
iPhones iPads on and then it IKEA makes
these the builds available for internal
distribution you know pretty much right
away so it means that within our company
we've got on approved devices we've got
our appt deployed within minutes of it
actually being checked in so this is
great all this is continuous deployment
on iOS and we're done and I'm going home
but but not really um so the thing is
that we still wanted to be really sure
that when we submitted something to
Apple that it actually worked on because
we don't have we it's going to take us
four to seven days to correct a mistake
so unreasonably sensibly we said okay
we're going to put a period at the end
so we're going to have this period at
the top we call this the Alpha period
and that's where you know Jerry's doing
is our long or few hours of check-ins
and commits and we're getting continuous
deploys and then we're going to have a
code freeze and then we're going to have
a testing period which we call our beta
period it's kind of an internal data
really and we're going to we're going to
just do a bunch of testing during that
we can make absolutely sure that what we
have is great and then we submit it to
apple on and this seems like a really
good idea it's basically continuous
deployment with a little safety net and
then you know you send it out and it
works but but it didn't work and I'll
talk about why it didn't work and
basically we'd solve this batch size
problem in theory because we now are
committing these small batches but
nobody actually use these like we
deployed these things to company devices
we don't score baseball games during the
middle of the day in January
in our jobs like you know maybe if we
were working at like Twitter this
actually would have just worked fine but
for us like we don't happen to squirt
baseball games for fun as part of our
natural like our daily life so nobody
used this stuff so what we thought was
going to look like this you know we kind
of had we're kind of had this problem
while all the testing in our process
happened here at the end um and this was
bad so what we have is like what we tend
to do the way we test is we've got you
know we write at the end we have an app
release Canada that's ready to go out we
run through a test plan on it some
manual some automatic and then when it
passes we ship well if it fails only
again we fix something and we rerun the
test plan and if it fails we do it again
and what was happening was we were doing
like five to ten turns of this process
so we would you know we'd have a release
candidate we'd be really excited well it
would fail and then someone go fix
something and then we'd try again and it
would fail again because the fix broke
something else and try again and fail
again it was you know not good obviously
wasteful because essentially this week
we were just we were just felt like we
were kind of wasting our time trying
things over and over again and and
sometimes it was more than a week in
terms of risk it's kind of hard to
visualize risk you know especially when
things are working I'll attempt to do it
here this is a graph of crashes per
session it means essentially percentage
of app sessions that end in it crash and
so if you can't read these numbers the
top line is four percent which isn't
actually not a super-high crash rate
well I have some apps on my phone the
crash a lot more than four percent of
the time to you know the middle line is
two percent and these horizontally these
are our appt releases so this is like a
release that's about now is about two
years old and and here we're getting too
about a year ago so this is is the the
crash procession rate um and what we
noted notice here is we care about our
crashes like we don't want this these to
go up but despite the fact that we were
like trying to prevent crashes like our
crash rate was kind of creeping upwards
and I kind of tells me that there was
you know that things were leaking
through our process we were taking risks
and we hit a crisis last year what
happened actually like a year ago this
week was that we had this is at this
high point where we had about a four
percent rate which again is not like
horrible but the horrible thing was that
the what happened was that the people
who hit these crashes couldn't recover
from them so we had some percentage of
our customers some large percentage of
our customers you couldn't use the app
that flooded our customer service team
this also is right at the beginning of
baseball season so I know it seems
ridiculous to play baseball right now
because it's cold outside they're like
actually people in warm parts of the
country who are playing baseball right
now and our choosing tools are going to
use for the entire season and so having
this happen at the beginning of the
season meant some impact to our business
that you know basically hey you know
what this tool that I choose isn't
working so maybe I'll go use something
else and that's something we expedited a
release we got it fixed but we did some
damage and so basically this this idea
which is a good one at this continuous
pre production deployment didn't and
followed by this testing like overlap at
the end it didn't work well enough and
you know because we had some waste and
we had some risks that we need to get
rid of so we'll talk about how we how we
kind of got through that so there really
two ways that we considered for kind of
how do we get how do we kind of get this
feedback problem under control all of
our testing was happening here and and
that was creating a bunch of risk for us
so so one thing we said was well we
could just adeline a bunch of padding
and we actually kind of had to do this
for a bit while we were just kind of
getting things same again like you know
we could just take a more time and test
more and make everything better um
tanning kind of sucks though it's like a
way of surrendering to a inefficient
process it's a way of like
institutionalizing the slow feedback
problem we had institutionalizing like a
kind of de facto big batch size that we
had I kind of view padding is like you
know management's way of encouraging
waste so we had to do this for a bit but
we didn't really like it what we really
wanted to do was say okay let's make
feedback happen faster let's make the
testing happen sooner um and then the
only question is how do you do that well
I mean there's some obvious things here
so so obviously we're going to we're
going to be fought automation because
automation and can give us some feedback
in terms of unit testing we have a
little bit of a PM testing the screen
shot yesterday the red thing is green
now so I stole of credibility there were
you know we improved our unit test count
by I think we were probably 10 or 15 X
improvement in terms of unit tests count
so this is important I don't think this
is really the interesting part I mean
people do you know test but it's not
this alone wouldn't give me a lot of
confidence in terms of releasing our app
really what it came down to was well
let's generate more feedback with these
like you know builds that we got you
know if we got these we've got this
continuous build thing that goes and
puts builds on people's phones now let's
use it so how are we going to do that um
so yeah and these are people like these
are six people um I know like this is
like this is the continuous delivery
meetup not the sharepoint Mita so I'm
not like I might have just jumped the
shark by showing pictures of people
especially you know like to meet ups ago
the guy was like hey you know what like
don't buy tools and everyone went
and now I'm like well you know don't
like you know use people or do use
people we're going to think I'm crazy I
don't mean that we went like went on a
hiring spree like all these guys
actually already worked with us these
folks we we said you know what like you
these are contractors I'm the customer
service team on the right hand side we
said you spend an extra three hours a
week well we'll kind of tell you what to
what to do personal on top left is a
full-time tester a person here came on
from the seat the customer service team
as a half-time tester and then this
person in the tire here is a designer
which you could probably derive from
first principles but so I'm going to do
is really talk about kind of how these
people kind of helped us generate
feedback in a really systematic
repeatable disciplined way so so in
order to like distribute builds
regularly to people who would use them
we needed to make our tooling a little
bit better we made our build scripts
better we rewrote them we took our build
server moved it to mack stadium which is
you know essentially just max in the
cloud with a fast connection basically
took like time warner cable out of our
way out of the critical path of our of
our release cycle which is great you
know we have automatic release notes now
so that whenever one of these testers
gets a new build they see it release
notes and then this thing which like
ought to be trivial but it kind of isn't
because Apple makes something's really
hard on you we made it possible to
install our alpha builds our beta builds
and our production bills on the same
device it's just a bunch of script bunch
of hackery and stuff but you know I took
us a while to figure out how to do that
so yeah we improved our tooling and then
we kind of just went like really old
school this is a checklist these are
people's names at the top of the
checklist these are them checking that
they actually tested things we had
automated tests like as I said we did
some automation but there were a lot of
things especially for an app like ours
with with really high usability demands
really high the reason why if you can
think of like kind of keeping up with a
game at game speed under the kind of
stress you're under when you know like
someone takes a shot misses rebound
takes another shot misses takes another
shot is fouled and that happens in span
of like one and a half seconds and you
need to record all of it like I I'm not
confident releasing unless I people
trying these things and then none of us
are so but but in other respects this
was a lot like a kind of a build process
that were used to well if these guys are
now sweeping through three times a week
and running through their test list if
they find anything then somebody jumps
on it right away you know as if like you
know as if like the build went red now
this also forced us to do some feature
flagging because we're now building
these we're now committing in small
increments and well we've got people who
need to be able to test the app all the
time and so or you know at least three
times a week so if we had a feature
that's not yet baked enough to be tested
like two developers might be working on
it simultaneously but it's not ready for
these guys what we feature flag until
it's ready and turn it on kind of at its
earliest point that we can so another
thing we did also involving people was
we made usability testing happen on a
regular frequent schedule so twice a
week so this is our basketball interface
we rewrote we redesigned our basketball
interface we launched basketball last
year we've learned a bunch of stuff from
it and then we decided that we were
going to revamp how it worked and so we
we were usability testing our changes
twice a week so what's showing here is
the foul flow so when somebody fouls
another player in basketball so we had a
version of this that we designed we
liked
we went out we tested it we hated it and
so then we we did this like three or
four times we had something that passed
testing that we felt was good enough and
the really cool thing about this was
kind of the team dynamic that it created
because the designing and we were 30
person company ten people are on our
engineering team three people on our
design team great ratio we all sit right
next to each other some in stand-ups
every morning it would it would
basically be a designer would say hey
I'm going out tonight to test our appt
at west fourth street basketball courts
and you know I know you guys are working
on the foul flow you know can I have
something to work on and you know people
were kind of talk and say well know
initially I wasn't planning on doing
that but yeah you know I'll reorder what
I'm doing so I can get you something
that you can test right away so you know
they go out they test come back say hey
you know here's what I learned this kind
of sucks kind of regroup we figure out
how it's going to work so it so created
like this really good dynamic and as an
engineering team we were really excited
because we had really fast feedback on
like whether our stuff was actually
working on and the designers like the
two because well they could actually
have input and see it build women a few
hours so I was great so so this is good
right you know we're taking this testing
now and we're moving it from here to
here and so things should get better
right and it didn't really get better um
and we hadn't quite figured it out yet
so this is again the number of beta
builds oh I don't think I've shown those
people this is the number of beta builds
it's a number of turns of our beta
testing cycle we're doing at the end of
every release this top line is the
number 10 which is tan beta builds which
means they're essentially repeating our
process about 10 times in the middle is
5 and what basically seeing is except
for this one outlier for every release
we were doing like five or more turns of
this like beta process which is kind of
expensive and kind of a waste of time
and we're just kind of waiting you know
like ideally we freeze we test it once
and we submit it
we don't waste any time and instead
we're doing this like five times so it
didn't work and and that kind of stunk
and it took us a while to figure out
what was going on um so we have here is
on the left is Eric who's our tester and
Elena who's his assistant and eric is
actually tells me he is actually testing
our app in this photo which is awesome
so Eric's job is kind of kind of kind of
cool like he he he has both
responsibility and authority for
shipping a good app which means he's the
guy who presses the button for our app
to go to apple and then presses the
button again when the app is approved so
that the universe can can download it
and start using it and his mandate is
pretty much you don't press the button
until you're confident Eric takes up
incredibly seriously and that's great we
realized that we had a we ended up
figuring out we had a problem with
visibility because Eric doesn't brag a
lot which is good he what he would do
was before just before he would go and
submit the app to Apple he'd go looking
Trello which is where we do our project
management he look at all the stuff we
done for a release he dig through it and
he would just crazy test everything in
there and then he'd always find some
kind of miracle bug right at the end we
were like oh my god Eric like thank
goodness she found that because
otherwise like we would have died and so
we give each other a bunch of high fives
and everything and this process repeats
a couple times and this is great like
Eric was like a game-changer we talked
about like being a good teammate like
Eric was being a great teammate he was
like helping us out he was going in and
figuring out what he need to do to be
confident in shipping the only problem
was that we actually didn't know he was
doing this because he was a nice guy and
so when we realized that this is what
was happening that Eric was kind of
stuck in this last week there was this
hidden part of our process that we
actually didn't know about
and well obviously we just need to move
Eric and Lena a little bit earlier in
the process and so okay great now we
know what the problem is so we let's
make it visible though let's have a
column and Trello that just says hey you
know let's when something needs to get
when it's on Eric's list of stuff to
look at will keep it in a separate
column and we'll move it to Don as soon
as it's done and well this is great but
it was too much work and it started to
pile up and well then then then Joe
showed up we chose this guy here and and
we're like hey you know Joe you're your
customer service guy we could you spend
like kind of half your time working with
us we can probably save you enough time
and customer service that it's you know
worth your time Joe is like a sure okay
so so Joe came on Jim came on board full
time and what we saw was this is our
beta build graph again so again the top
line is ten turns of the of the beta
testing cycle and this middle one is
five so when we started tracking testing
we had like one more release around here
and then we started like getting a lot
faster at shipping stuff and so this is
basically between one and three turns of
beta it could be dumb luck I mean this
is only five times in a row so there you
know we could have just been lucky a few
times I don't think it was I also in
stone like I'm not going to be here and
say like having to repeat the same
process three times it's wonderful um I
think this is actually a case where
automation is going to help us get
better there are some legacy parts of
our app that are not automate that that
for which testing is not automated and
they're not written in a in a well
testable way and actually we have a team
that is forming around doing just that
probably within the next month or so so
I think that like to kind of get from
this like we got from like five to ten
down to one two three which is great to
get that next up I think we're going to
have to automate some you know some of
the harder to test aspects of the system
um but the cool thing was that
like kind of a more concrete way of
saying it was that we don't really talk
about testing week anymore it kind of is
only a couple days because it doesn't
take five days to do just a couple turns
of our cycle so that's good the other
thing that happened was crash rate so
this again is number of a percent of
sessions that end in a crash we kind of
got back down to here and lower than
where we've even been previously about a
third to a tenth of where we were at our
like kind of a tower you know depending
on where you measure like you know
whether you measure from our worst point
or average point but we got a lot better
um so this is progress like we you know
in terms of fast delivery I kind of
intact as delivery we've we've been
shipping every three weeks pretty much I
think our average has gone from like 23
to 21 days we could make it faster this
is still probably about as fast as any
iOS app ships we did we did reduce waste
so I mean we cut the amount of turns of
that data cycle we reduce risk when your
crash rate is lower and we just
generally are more confident that we're
catching things in our testing cycle and
and we even had some kind of cool side
effects like our now that we've got
these builds that are being regularly
generated and people are regularly using
them and we have the tools to distribute
them well like one of the guys in our
marketing team just started demoing or
alphas to customers and so initially my
initial reaction this was like terror
like oh my god what are you doing and
then I was like wait you're giving this
more feedback that's great if you just
kind of realize that all these features
that he wanted to show off to convince
people to use game-changer were
pre-release and he had enough confidence
in us that he would show them and we
were happy because if I think brokey
tell us about it so it's kind of cool
kind of a neat side effect so in terms
of how this applies in your environment
and environments and aren't like ours um
so this is this where we started Fred
Wilson saying big changes create big
problems little changes created
old problems and the model doesn't work
for desktop software and mobile apps
well the little change model works great
it works great for us and mobile apps it
just looks different and if we're
talking about like by-the-book
continuous delivery versus what we did I
mean you know automation versus some
manual miss you know large sample a/b
testing versus like usability testing
this isn't really the important part
right like what we did to make this fast
feedback happen was it's not that
important what is important is this idea
of small batches like getting your
getting our batches down really small we
figured out the ways to do that that
worked with us you know which had to do
with these these like you know
distribution through hockey AB and then
we figured out how to solve this problem
which is getting feedback to happen
really quickly how you make this happen
isn't that important like if you're
doing enterprise apps it's going to be
different than if you're doing ours or
you've got an app that your employees
tend to use versus one that your
employees don't tend to use it's going
to be different our techniques were like
ancient right any usability testing
manual QA um the cool thing we did with
them was we just made them happen very
quickly in very small batches made
feedback happened really fast so that's
it well thank you and I'd love to take
maybe a couple questions if people have
them yeah
yeah so the question was on the web his
company uses something called Casper jas
which essentially stimulates button
clicks and verifies behavior of the
website and to end and is there a tool
for doing that for apps so there are a
few tools we use a tool called appium
which is it's basically selenium for
apps like it essentially your client
code speaks the selenium protocol and on
the back end is this massive hack that
goes and drives an iOS simulator and our
experience that has been up and down we
do use it and we do have some automation
around it but we're not like kind of
heavily heavily invested in it yet next
question hi on this separate alpha beta
so the answer on server is by default
alpha beta and production builds all run
against our production server there are
tricks you can use to get them to run
against other other environments but by
default they'd run on the production
server your second question was on on
how do we get them to run separately and
i'm forgetting i think it was was bundle
identifier it was basically we just went
to info.plist and hack the hell out of
it until we you know we have a script
that just goes and exit witches out ID
so that we can separately install apps
yeah earlier you mentioned that use
Jenkins do you still use that or to use
bill BOTS and Xcode 5 on your cloud
service um quiet question was whether we
use Jenkins or build lots so we still
use Jenkins I'm reasonably happy with
Jenkins we use a little bit of Travis CI
for some of our open source libraries um
I'm not it I don't have enough
experience with Bill BOTS to really say
a lot about them i like the flexibility
that Jenkins has to kind of do whatever
it does its own kind of plotting
frustrating way and also I so yeah I
don't I don't know enough about Bill
BOTS to really say I have a question you
mentioned it seems like you guys are
relying a lot of manual testing how do
you manage the balance between manually
verifying that new functionality behaves
the way it should and that it doesn't
cause regressions because I'm assuming
that as you progress your regression
test suite gets larger and larger and
you only have so many testers it's a
good question um we are simultaneous i
mentioned like our automated count went
up about you know 10 or 15 X so my
vision for how manual testing is going
to work is that as our automation gets
better our manual testers are able to
get more anal but ultimately we're
we're basically like have a time limit
on the amount of time that we're going
to spend on manual on on especially on
like the regression testing part of
manual testing so we're putting pressure
on ourselves to automate the things that
can be well automated still though when
we build so that's for regression
testing still as we build new features i
think i really want to have like some
gameplay experience to as part of
testing new features to make sure we
have confidence that's kind of a half
answer I mean we're pushing we're
pushing hard on automation but we know
that manual testing is going to remain
part of our process oh hi oh sorry and
you you mentioned anecdote about
usability testing where one of your
colleagues goes down to four straight
west forth to test out the app is that
how you guys today still do usability
testing that standard example and I
guess the reason I'm asking is I found
it odd that he left had to leave to go
do usability testing I could have
thought he'd just fire up YouTube clip
or whatever of some game in the past and
you know there's tons of testing
scenarios it aren't exists he doesn't
have to we've done both west north and
hope that like these scenarios work out
yeah we've done we've done both to be
honest there is a there's a certain
advantage to being in the chaos of an
environment that like simulates the
amount of stress you can be under walls
scorekeeping we also do a ton of testing
with what YouTube clips or are like
games and you know we sometimes we'll
we'll just like kind of go through a
ESPN gamecast of a game that was like
scored a year ago and and for some
reason like Eric always picks games of
my teams lose and makes me test them but
yeah we do we do and make sure both of
those things
hey got a few questions so first okie
app does it require users to install the
app manually or does it automatically
install the new versions for new
versions what it does is when you when
you launch the app it will check with
hockey app and you get a little pop-up
saying hey there's a new alpha release
available and here are the release notes
for would you like to download it okay
then next when you're working on the
release and you're in the beta phase do
your main developer still work on master
or do you cut through this branch are
you cutter release branch when we get
the data okay and let's see for your CI
machines you mentioned mack stadium is
that where you run all your builds and
your app m tests yes
so you say you get a release out to
Apple roughly once every three weeks
right is that how then Apple reviews
those regularly and and in the end users
see a new version about every three
weeks yes basically what happens you
give it to apple and then their review
process is basically a black box you get
some status updates that are meaningless
and then a few days later they say hey
your app is ready for sale what's what's
the the highest number of the the
highest rate of bills you could
conceivably release to Apple that they
would tolerate could you release to them
daily and they'd be okay with that or
were they you can't you can't have two
builds in the pipeline at the same time
so we could release them probably once a
week and get a and we would probably get
away with it all right thanks where they
get what they've told us is we get in
trouble if we release if if we release a
lot of bad builds to them and they have
to go and do crazy things to expedite
releases and that's when they start
penalizing us least that's what they
told us but I haven't I haven't
personally tried to go in and pump
builds to them every week and and so
they haven't been pushed back on this
yet it's a gots a good point actually
people didn't hear that your reviews
refresh every release so let's say that
your yeah your your if you got a five
star app and you push a new release the
default view and Apple shows reviews for
the current release and so you suddenly
have a unreviewed app it's kind of yeah
kind of sucks
I've got a couple questions down here
the microphones are what's the so I
understand that running functional test
with a PM can be pretty challenging and
that's not stable but it seems like you
can have a lot of benefits to cover a
lot of devices and West versions what
was a pushback against two to favor more
manual testing versus automatic testing
I mean give you an example of like a of
a bug that we found in manual testing
which i think is fairly common are a
fairly common concern that we have
you're swiping the court to change
possession during basketball we had a
case where the court would hiccup while
you were swiping that kind of doesn't
seem like a big deal until again you're
watching a basketball game and trying to
record a change of possession and like
route you know like everything goes nuts
and there was a performance problem deep
in our statistics code that would find
that kind of thing there are a bunch of
like interaction level things that were
that only people are going to be able to
find any and an app like the one that we
release now it doesn't mean that I don't
want to use appium we use a peon it's
just I want to use a peanut things that
a PM is good at so it seems like you
have kind of an inner loop of feedback
and then a bigger loop of feedback for
the things that you do release how but
with that feedback by the time you get
that you're already a couple of inner
loops beyond how do you manage those
different cycles that's a really good
question um i would say that we don't
have a formal process around that we do
keep an eye on so it's like one example
that feedback is crash rate so we do
because we have a pretty small team we
keep we just kind of regularly keep an
eye on kind of how the outer loop of
feedback is working with crash rates in
the wild and then we see what's actually
happening we bring it back in but right
now it's kind of a very informal social
process we haven't systematized that
like outer loop feedback back and
the inner loop we also have a customer
service team that is you know seeing the
outer loop and is sending cases to us
and so sometimes we get like outer loop
feedback come to us enough times that
were like oh we need to do something
about this
have you ever tried baking any
instruments checks and your automated
builds like the you know memory leaks
let it bake for a while and run
interactions on and stuff like that and
then get some blogs and automate that
that's a good idea and we haven't done
that yet we are running clang in our
automatic builds like static analysis
but we aren't we aren't yet doing
instruments checks and I actually don't
know what the issues we run into it that
are but it's something we should
investigate cool great well thank you
guys